starwars the last Jedi has arrived at
last leaving audiences thrilled amazed
and emotionally spent not to mention
totally wondering exactly what the heck
is gonna happen next
unfortunately that next isn't going to
arrive until episode 9 hits theaters in
2019 but at least that gives fans plenty
of time to speculate about just what
we're likely to see when this story
finally concludes with that in mind
here's a spoiler filled look at some of
the biggest and answered questions in
the last Jedi why did Luke die just as
it seemed all hope was lost for the
resistance at the end of the last Jedi
the actual last Jedi showed up with a
new hope in the form of a cool force
projection from across the galaxy and
then after giving the others time to
escape he dropped dead for no apparent
reason but why was the strain of
projecting himself across the galaxy too
much did kylo Ren's lightsaber attacks
somehow actually injure Luke in the same
way Kylie was able to reach out and
physically touch Rey from across the
galaxy or did Luke simply become one
with the force after redeeming himself
and finally finding balance all we know
for sure is like Yoda before him Luke
just suddenly wrapped it on out of there
leaving behind nothing but a sweaty old
Jedi Snuggie why though is anyone's
guess where Stokes guards actually
Luke's other students when Luke explains
to Rey will happen between him and kylo
Ren he states that Ben solo turned to
the dark side slew several of Luke's are
the students and then took off with the
rest so what happened to those other
students is it possible they ended up as
snoke's personal guards after all those
mysterious Red Cloud Warriors were
almost powerful enough to take out kylo
Ren and right at the same time of course
if those were Luke's other students why
wasn't anybody looking for them and
trying to save them instead of only
worrying about kylo Ren all the time and
if they weren't Luke's other students
does that mean some of Luke's other
students might still be alive somewhere
is Snoke really dead there was a ton of
speculation over the last couple of
years over Supreme Leader Snoke stru
identity and then he abruptly got cut in
half of a lightsaber making all that
speculation pointless whoops but is he
really dead one of the leading theories
about snoke's true identity was the idea
that he was actually Darth Plagueis a
Sith Lord who was so incredibly powerful
he actually mastered death itself if
that's true then it's possible snow
possibly return from the dead in episode
9 and hey Darth Maul somehow came back
from being cut in half by grafting weird
spider legs to his torso so as the
galaxy going to be menaced by zombie
Snoke let the next two years of
speculation begin what are they going to
do with Leia when Carrie Fisher
tragically passed away in 2016
fans couldn't help but wonder how it
would affect the Star Wars universe
while Fisher had already finished
filming her scenes as general Leia for
the last Jedi Disney reportedly had to
completely rework the story for episode
9 to deal with the loss of one of the
franchise's most beloved characters but
how exactly are they going to handle it
in the story at the end of the last Jedi
Leia is still leading the ragtag group
of survivors from the resistance and is
confident she has all the tools she
needs to reform the movement and drive
out the first order but since Disney is
reportedly not going to use any footage
of Fisher in episode 9 or use CGI to
recreate her as they did in rogue one it
leaves a major question mark about how
they'll explain her absence why is Luke
really on the island when Rey shows up
and asks for Luke's help he very rudely
tells her to get lost informing her that
he came to the island to die in peace
which is a nice line in everything but
it doesn't make a lick of sense for
starters if he wanted to die why is he
still like alive and more importantly if
he really wanted to be alone so darn
badly why did he leave behind the
detailed maps showing exactly how to
find them the whole thing seems like the
Jedi equivalent of Vega booking he
really went away because he just wanted
someone to come find them and ask what's
wrong but you thought kylo Ren was the
emo one what's in the cave Jedi trainees
sure do love going into evil caves to
confront the dark side but Rey's trip
into the blow hole of ultimate evil left
us with more questions and answers when
she first senses the cave
Luke is horrified at how willingly she
approaches the darkness that dwells were
then but not horrified enough to cancel
the next lesson they agree that there
must be something Rey needs inside the
cave something that calls to her and yet
when she actually goes inside to find
out what the deal is
she only finds a mirror that provides
her with nothing at all so what was rage
one two in the cave that was so
important because whatever it is she
didn't seem to actually find it what a
lairs powers fans have been salivating
at the idea of Leia becoming a Jedi
Knight
it was first revealed in Return of the
Jedi that she's Luke's sister and can
also use the Force
but other than occasionally gazing into
the middle distance and the mumbling
someone's name she never seemed to use
any of her powers until the last Jedi
when she suddenly went full-on star
wizard in a crazy sequence when she used
her abilities to survive the vacuum of
space and even fly through it which begs
a question how the heck did she do that
when did she undergo training what else
can she do Leia's powers have never been
explored but flying around in space like
your Iron Man awesome things suggests
that Leia has a whole bag of tricks we
never knew about and sadly are never
likely to see again what does pork taste
like it's true that last Jedi leaves a
lot of questions open to debate but for
our money the one question we really
want answered is what pork tastes like
in one of the most wrenching scenes in
the film
Chewbacca tries to eat a roast pork only
to be accosted by the poor beasts
distraught family they tried to guilt
him into not eating their cousin
although by that point that damage was
kind of already done and it looked
delicious like a juicy tender chicken
roasted to perfection but does it taste
like chicken or as a name implies as a
close at the pork pork the other other
white meat it does kind of have a ring
to it thanks for watching click the loop
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know your love tank